a six one seven eight three zero 4750
let's go to the seven five seven area
code who's calling from seven five seven
today hello its Ernest
hey Ernest what's going on I want to
talk to you about your position on
nucular now that the IPCC came out and
since we got 12 years to go for this
Armageddon with the global warming diet
you have to really tamper down a new
terrorist that maybe we should go all-in
instead okay
I'm not for all in on nuclear so that
that part I'm clear on I will tell you
what what my position is though in a
sort of more intermediate way on nuclear
I'm okay now so let me give you the
logistical restriction first it takes a
while to get new nuclear capacity online
okay so that's something that we have to
think about it's not like we decide
today to do something with nuclear and
in a month or a year we're generating
power right it takes takes a while to
get new supply on but I would be open to
using nuclear as a bridge to get off of
fossil fuels and to renewables if and
these are some really big IFS number one
it comes with the immediate removal of
subsidies on dirty fossil fuels as the
nuclear supply comes online and number
two it's part of the plan from the
get-go that this is only temporary this
is only a bridge and renewables and
green energy must be developed within a
very particular amount of time okay so I
am I understand the risks of nuclear I
also do understand that at this point if
we built new nuclear we would be using
very different standards than were used
earlier in the 20th century and that as
a bridge I'm open to it but I am not on
an all-in on nuclear guy well well what
I have to counter with is that we can
just do like a mass production sort of
nuclear make it module make it small and
didn't mass produce it as much as
possible that we can get down on cost
and standardize the safety and make
should make sure that this reactor is so
he's okay sure but I would still I would
still favor not going to nuclear for the
long term and having to deal with
disposal and all sorts of other issues
and just going to something that doesn't
have to be developed to be safe it
simply is safe systemically at its core
what we do have things like on the edge
of ready to be pushed out like molten
salt reactors I'm not familiar with that
researcher yeah
molten salt reactors would be the best
replacement we can make the modular and
then we can just simply have them run
off of the nuclear waste that we already
have so we don't have to make any new
fuel we can use it as a solution and
actually deal with the toxic waste
problem we already have okay I don't
know enough about it to say whether
you're representing it fairly or not but
I will I will research it and and
comment with when I feel I've got a firm
enough grasp of it a channel you can
look into is Gordon McDowell he has
plenty of resources on this ok I'm not
familiar with them you could be
recommending someone who's wacky or
someone who's a very very insightful on
the matter I will check it out I really
appreciate the call thank you for
calling in